the chest drama is back Magnus Carlson
the greatest chess player on the planet
has shocked the world this month after
losing to 19 year old Hans Neiman
withdrawing from a tournament because of
it resigning in one move the next time
the pair played each other and being
generally cryptic about his implication
of why all of this has happened that
Hans has been cheating it's been three
weeks of absolutely jam-packed drama but
finally Magnus has spoken out but what
he said might be more disturbing than
the silence that came before
[Music]
foreign
to a lot of Chess channels out there
because of all this drama ones that I
didn't even know existed beforehand
maybe you're watching this and you're
new to Esports well consider subscribing
to the channel we have lots of great
videos just like this one also leave us
a like on your way out the door if you
enjoyed the video cheers three and a
half weeks ago Magnus Carlson faced off
against Hans Neiman in the third round
of the esteemed singfield cup now on
paper Magnus was the clear favorite he's
a five-time world champion who up until
that game have been on a 53-game
undefeated streak now for some people he
might genuinely be the greatest chess
player to ever play this one and a half
thousand year old game Neiman on the
other hand was a talented 19 year old
American who although having recently
risen rapidly in the world rankings was
not expected to beat Magnus but it seems
nobody told him that because that's
exactly what he did H4 and G4 set up
because it doesn't yeah and there there
we have it handshake
there we have it wow what a result guys
truly
wow I can just imagine the chat going uh
nuts at this point like uh what do we
what have we witnessed it was pretty
astounding stuff but it was what
happened next that kick-started this
month-long drama the day after the loss
Magnus tweeted out saying that he had
withdrawn from the tournament he added a
famous clip of football manager Jose
Mourinho not wanting to speak his mind
in an interview I prefer really not to
not to speak if I speak I am in in big
trouble
in big trouble and I don't want to be in
big trouble the message between the
lines that everyone got was that Magnus
was accusing Hans of cheating and
everything pretty much exploded from
that moment here was the world champion
essentially calling out a fellow
professional for the most heinous crime
you can commit in any competitive scene
but especially chess cheating longtime
rival of Magnus and popular streamer
Hikaru Nakamura broke down what might
have been going through magnus's mind at
the time I'm gonna try to speculate here
on magnus's intentions I think that
Magus believes Magnus believes that Hans
probably is cheating again unproven who
knows what the reality is he probably
does believe that and it's harder part
that Hans cheated in that game or that
he is cheating or whatever okay so if
Magnus believes that what is Magnus
gonna do in the situation if he really
believes that okay if you go out and you
say something but you have no proof then
you're then like then I mean the burden
proof is extremely high of course
because like if it's not done at the
time of year of the game of course you
can't prove anything
um and so you really have no way proving
that if you really believe that so so I
think magnus's way of basically saying
that is like he's not going to actually
say it but he's putting out this clip
saying if I talk him in trouble and he's
withdrawing to make the point without
publicly making the point man that were
many theories being thrown around to
support this some people were saying
that Hans wasn't able to explain his win
properly in the post-match interview
others have said that over the last few
years Hans has had a suspiciously
meteoric rise to become one of the top
50 players in the world Neiman fired
back at Hikaru on Twitter for making
what he called frivolous implications on
the tournament stream he also addressed
something that had been brought up a lot
in support of magnus's implications the
fact that Hans had cheated on two known
occasions before he was Keen to
emphasize that these games happened
online when he was 12 and 16 years old
and that this tournament was an entirely
different thing I wanted to gain some
rating you know I just wanted to get
Harry ready to play Stronger players so
I cheated in random games on just.com
now I was confronted I confessed and
this is the singer the biggest mistake
in my life and I'm completely ashamed
and I'm telling the world because
I do not want any misrepresentation and
I do not want rumors I have never
cheated in an over the board game
other when I was 12 years old I have
never ever ever and I would never do
that that is the worst thing I could
ever do cheat in a tournament with prize
money and in the wake of all of this
chess.com also Uninvited Hans from their
world championship they said they'd
share detailed evidence with Hans that
contradicts his statements on the amount
and seriousness of his cheating on
chess.com now chess.com and a single
field cup are two separate entities but
you couldn't help notice the timing of
all of this it felt like hans's career
was being put through the shredder while
the general public was missing one
pretty key part of the story actual
proof in the absence of that the chess
Community began to furiously speculate
about how Hans Could Have Cheated if all
of this was true and some of the
theories got pretty ridiculous that's
probably a good one right an anal bead
probably would beat the thing I I'm
serious if the engine I
it would probably
I don't know I really don't know like
think about it I don't know so this
crazy idea is that Hans was receiving
signals via anal beads from an outside
Source presumably with a chess computer
to act as a guide for what move to make
next and I'm not going to go into any
more details on that now incredibly this
posting actually gained some traction to
the point where it became the central
Focus for some in the media a campsite
even offered Hans one million dollars to
play a game of chess naked to prove the
haters wrong once and for all and in
some ways I don't blame people for
focusing on the whole anal beads angle
because in many ways the story just
wasn't advancing but then on September
19th Magnus and Hans faced off once
again for the first time since that
fateful game this time it was an online
game in the Julius bear generation cup
everyone held their breath who was gonna
win would Magnus get his revenge would
this be a chance for everyone to leave
all this drama behind and just get back
to playing some chess
oh no
no no no no no no no no no it was a very
very good game it was probably an
inspired game you could call it but is
it an obvious proof of cheating
definitely not I don't think he cheated
in the same field cup but everything
else is still sorry sorry Alejandra I
just have to interrupt you because the
game started
um and Magnus has logged off what has
happened Magnus has resigned
Magnus has to resigned the game against
found me Mom
at least that's what it says in our
transmission
yes
it looks that way Magnus made one move
Knight to F6 and then disconnected Hans
followed shortly after this wasn't an
accident it was a statement from Magnus
that he was not going to play against
this opponent what a fantastic first
move who are you rooting for Hans or a
Carlson guys what
[Music]
what
what what happened the memes were
flooding in by this point as expected
the idea that the world champion of any
sport would show up just to instantly
resign with almost too bizarre to parody
but the internet did it anyway while
there was a lot of confused laughter it
was also a growing sense that this just
wasn't okay for over three weeks Magnus
had kept the chess community in the dark
about what he actually thought and for
three weeks 19 year old Honda's career
was being irrevocably changed to put it
simply some people felt that Magnus was
taking the piss it was time for him to
make a statement instead of mysterious
withdrawals and resignations it was time
to chill get off the pot I think it's
fair to be suspicious of somebody who
literally self-admittedly cheated online
and is now crushing people over the
board would you agree I mean it's fair
to
and I think this is where you know the
arguments might start well maybe not
I don't think it's fair the way this is
being handled by Magnus at that time
finally came this week on Monday 22 days
after he quit the singfield cup Magnus
finally released a statement on Twitter
Magnus acknowledged that his actions had
frustrated many in the chess Community
but stressed that he himself was
frustrated too and that he just wanted
to play chess then he outlined how
cheating poses an existential threat to
chess itself the chess organizers and
lovers of the game should look at
increasing security and chest detection
for over-the-board chess then Magnus
honed in on Han specifically saying that
he's strongly considered withdrawing
from a single cup when he heard hands
had been a last minute invite this
showed that Magnus already had his
suspicions about Hans before their game
it wasn't like he was okay and then
decided to withdraw based off this game
alone he already had this on his mind
going into it after that Magnus got a
bit more specific he stated that he
believed Hans had cheated more and more
recently than he has publicly admitted
he cited his progress in best as unusual
and that during their game he had the
impression that Hans didn't seem to be
concentrating at critical moments like
he should how well Hans played as black
was also mentioned as a factor but the
final paragraph is perhaps the most key
here Magnus said that there is more he
would like to say but that he is limited
in what he can say without explicit
permission from Hans to speak openly he
said that he has only been able to speak
so far with his actions and that those
actions show he is not willing to play
chess with Hans he finished by saying he
hopes the truth will come out whatever
it may be so there we go honestly
there's a lot to unpack there but
paradoxically not a lot has actually
been said we thought that even when
Magnus decided to talk about this he
might provide some evidence he has not
it's quite strange that Magnus has said
he can't provide anything more of this
time without permission from Hans what
exactly does that mean would this
permission offer Magnus legal protection
some of these answers just create more
questions also a large chunk of the
statement is dedicated to combating
cheating in chess generally this is of
course something I'm sure everyone can
get behind and from what I've heard it
is an issue for the game but honestly it
kind of feels like Magnus is sort of
hiding behind this very honorable cause
when people just want to know what his
proof is and that's not just because
people love all of this drama although
I'm sure on some level that is true
increasingly it's because people just
feel bad for Hans what does Magnus mean
when he says that Hans has cheated more
and more recently than he's admitted to
is he sitting on proof of that sure
Magnus could very well be right hands
could be cheating and if so that should
be dealt with through the proper
channels but if he's not been cheating
then this whole thing just sucks if he's
not been cheating we have a 19 year old
guy who might be one of the most
promising American talents of his
generation and his career is being torn
up as we speak and again this isn't even
about whether he did or didn't do it if
you're Magnus Carlson if you're the
biggest chess player on the planet
someone who everyone looks up to then
your words have real concept sequences
Magnus knows this Magnus knows his name
carries weight even if this doesn't get
resolved one way or the other Magnus
saying that he'll never play against
Hans again in the future it's time to
mount to a chest death sentence for him
why would tournament organizers bother
to invite Han to their tournaments
knowing that if he went up against
Magnus it would probably just end in a
farcical one move resignation they'd
rather just not invite him at all so
despite this statement we're still just
as in the dark as we were before there
is still no guarantee that Magnus has
categorical proof to support his claims
and even if he does it sounds like there
are barriers stopping him from sharing
it now the day before magnus's statement
one video gained a lot of traction in
the chess Community chess coach yosha
Iglesias shared a 23-minute video
outlining what she believed to be the
most incriminating evidence against Hans
Neiman using the let's check database I
recommend checking that video out not
because I know it's right one way or the
other but because it's been a ray of
solid statistical Sunshine In This Storm
of drama mudslinging and anal bead
accusations in another Twist from just
yesterday Vice published an article in
which they shared that Hans Neiman's
coach Maxim delugi admitted to cheating
in tournaments in 2017 and 2020
according to emails provided to them by
chess.com of their correspondence with
delugie naturally this is not the kind
of news that Hans Neiman would welcome
given the circumstances we all need to
be aware of this and of course if he
breaks the rules again or tries to join
a cash event he will be gone Danny Ranch
Chiefs us officer chess.com LLC alright
so those are the emails this is this is
wild
and we're only halfway through the
article no less this drama has been
going on for four weeks and it still
doesn't seem to be any end in sight it
feels like only Magnus can provide that
ending but trying to guess his next move
is starting to feel just as hard in real
life as it is on the chessboard
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock
foreign